[Música]
los distintos ecosistemas del planeta
pueden parecer permanentes pero en
realidad son vulnerables al colapso la
jungla puede convertirse en desierto y
los arrecifes en rocas incluso sin
mediar cataclismos como volcanes y
asteroides Qué hace a un ecosistema
fuerte y o débil frente al cambio la
respuesta está en la idad la
biodiversidad está compuesta por tres
elementos
interrelacionados la diversidad de los
ecosistemas de las especies y la
genética Cuanto más entrelazadas están
estas características más denso y
resistente se vuelve el tejido
analicemos la selva amazónica una de las
regiones más biodiversas del planeta por
sus complejos ecosistemas su enorme
mezcla de especies y la variedad
genética en esas especies estas son
lianas que trepan del suelo del Bosque
al follaje se entrelazan con los árboles
y forman gruesos tallos de madera que
sostienen árboles
altísimos ayudados por las lianas los
árboles dan semillas frutos y hojas a
los herbívoros como el tapir y el agutí
que diseminan sus semillas por todo el
bosque para que crezcan millones de
insectos comen las sobras y descomponen
y reciclan los nutrientes para crear un
suelo rico la selva es un enorme sistema
lleno de muchos sistemas más pequeños
como este cada uno repleto de especies
interconectadas cada eslabón le da
estabilidad al siguiente y fortalece La
ola de
biodiversidad ese tejido es reforzado
por la diversidad genética de cada
especie que les permite enfrentar los
cambios las especies sin diversidad
genética son mucho más vulnerables a
fluctuaciones causadas por el cambio
climático enfermedades o la
fragmentación del
hábitat cada vez que desaparece una
especie por su reserva genética
debilitada se desintegran partes de la
red Qué pasaría si tuviéramos que
eliminar una especie de la selva se
desmoronar el sistema Quizá no el
volumen de especies su diversidad
genética y la complejidad de los
ecosistemas forman una biodiversidad tan
rica que la brecha de una especie en el
tejido no lo hará desmoronarse
la selva puede seguir resistiendo y
recuperarse del cambio Pero eso no es
cierto en todos los casos en algunos
entornos eliminar solo un componente
importante puede socavar todo el sistema
veamos los arrecifes de coral muchos
organismos de una recife dependen del
coral este brinda microhábitats clave y
una base de refugio y cría a miles de
especies de peces crustáceos y moluscos
los corales también crean relaciones
interdependientes con hongos y bacterias
el coral en sí es un telar que hace
posible el tejido de la red de
biodiversidad eso lo convierte en un
organismo clave del que otros dependen
para
sobrevivir Entonces qué ocurre cuando
las prácticas de pesca destructivas
contaminan y acidifican los océanos y
debilitan o incluso Matan al coral
exactamente lo que imaginan la pérdida
de esta especie clave implica la pérdida
de sus dependientes también y amenaza a
toda la estructura de la recife los
ecosistemas las especies y la diversidad
genética juntos forman una trama
compleja de biodiversidad vital para la
supervivencia de los organismos
terrestres de la que los humanos también
somos parte con solo perder algunas
cebras nuestro bienestar estará
amenazado si cortamos muchos eslabones
nos arriesgamos a que se desmorone todo
el futuro es impredecible pero la
biodiversidad puede ayudarnos es la red
de seguridad que nos dará la
supervivencia tenemos las herramientas y
el conocimiento para salvar el mundo
Pero cuál es el siguiente paso visite
ed.ted.com bar inclinada Earth School
para obtener una hoja de ruta que puede
seguir y medidas concretas que puede
tomar para marcar la diferencia